Stranger Things is this cool new sorta mystery-scifi-horror-drama
type deal from Netflix.
It’s set in the 80s, and it borrows a lot
from the films of that time, like E.T., and
Alien.
The story begins with the disappearance of
a boy called Will from the town of Hawkins,
Indiana, and the mystery quickly deepens with
the appearance of a girl with psychic powers,
a shadowy government agency, and a monster
from another dimension.
By the end of the season Will is found but
there are still heaps of unresolved questions
– like what’s up with Hopper and the g-men?
What is the monster, and how does the Upside
Down work?
What happened to Eleven?
And why did Nancy hook up with the douchebag
Steve instead of the sensitive Jonathan?
Was it the hair?
It was probably the hair.
But still let’s have a look at what happened
in Stranger Things Season 1, beginning at
the very beginning.
In the fifties and sixties, the CIA conducted
secret experiments in a program called MKUltra,
using drugs like LSD to investigate mind control,
brainwashing and interrogation techniques
– which is a real thing that happened, by
the way – but in Stranger Things, some of
these experiments take place at the Hawkins
National Laboratory, led by a certain Dr.
Brenner.
And one of Brenner’s subjects back in the
day was a woman called Terry Ives.
We learn that Terry was pregnant while she
was being experimented on with drugs, so naturally,
her child was born with psychic powers – like
telekinesis.
Terry named the child Jane, but Jane was taken
away from her by Brenner, who covered up the
kidnapping saying Terry actually had a miscarriage.
Terry tried to sue Brenner to get her daughter
back, but these attempts failed, and Terry
seems to have declined into a drugged-out
stupor.
Meanwhile Jane grew up in the Hawkins lab,
where she was tattooed with her new name – Eleven.
Eleven calls Dr Brenner “papa”, which
might mean Dr. Brenner lied and told El that
he was her dad, or maybe he really is her
dad, maybe he had some relationship with Terry,
we don’t know.
But in any case El is treated cruelly at the
Lab.
Brenner subjects her to lots of experiments
– making her break things with her mind,
and perceive things from a distance.
Sometimes he put Eleven in a sensory deprivation
tank, where Eleven’s able to psychically
project herself into a weird dark void where
she can interact with people who are far away
– this is during the Cold War, so Brenner
and his CIA buddies use her to spy on Russians.
But also in this darkness Eleven encounters
a monster.
The monster presumably isn’t physically
in this dark space, but is in its own dimension,
the Upside Down, just as the Russian is in
Russia, and Eleven’s in the tank, but by
projecting herself through this dark space,
Eleven is able to reach across the dimensions,
and under the orders of Brenner, she makes
contact with the monster, somehow causing
“a tear in time and space”, making a gate,
a portal into the monster’s dimension, allowing
it to emerge into Hawkins.
In the commotion, Eleven escapes the Lab by
crawling through a drain pipe, meanwhile the
monster starts to hunt animals and people
in Hawkins – at the start of Episode 1,
it takes Will.
So this kicks off the human drama of the story
– we see Will’s mother Joyce frantically
trying to connect with her son, and Will’s
older brother Jonathan searching, in his angst
and alienation.
We see the cop Jim Hopper, still haunted by
his daughter’s death.
And when Eleven escapes from the Lab she groups
up with Will’s friends Mike and Lucas and
Dustin, who teach her loyalty and normalcy
and love, there’s also Mike’s sister Nancy,
who’s growing up, trying to work out who
she is, discovering sex – like, when we
first see Nancy, Dustin offers her some sausage
and pepperoni pizza, which Nancy declines,
and this refusal to ‘take the sausage’
kinda foreshadows her conflict over whether
to sleep with her boyfriend Steve, or to listen
to her friend Barb and stay a virgin.
Barb, for her part, dies and no one seems
to care, but Steve gets a redemption of sorts,
after being an asshole early on.
In the end, Nancy and Steve are together,
but there’s still a bit of a love triangle
with Jonathan.
So yeah, there’s some interesting drama
happening, but the really juicy mysteries
surround the Upside Down.
The Upside Down seems to be a sort of “alternate
dimension”.
It has the same stuff in in it as the real
world – all the buildings and trees and
cars of Hawkins are there – but everything’s
dark and dead and decayed, cold and empty.
When stuff moves or changes in the real Hawkins,
nothing seems to change or move in the Upside
Down, so it’s almost like this is a snapshot,
a frozen moment in time, perhaps of what Hawkins
was like at the moment of contact, when Eleven
touched the monster – maybe it was at that
moment that this whole dimension was created.
Or maybe the Upside Down used to be alive
and normal like Hawkins, but it was infected
by this weird toxic growth we see in the Upside
Down.
There are vines or tentacles on the ground,
slime on the walls, particles in the air,
the gate seems to grow, and wherever the monster
goes, slime spreads.
Maybe this is like an interdimensional disease,
spreading from parallel world to parallel
world, infecting the multiverse.
Or maybe this is a time travel thing.
Maybe the Upside Down is the future of Hawkins,
it’s what it’ll become after being infected
– by its own future.
This is all wild speculation, but whatever
the Upside Down is, it’s clearly closely
connected to Hawkins – the dimensions affect
each other in lots of different ways.
Activity in the Upside Down can cause electrical
disturbance in Hawkins, Will and Joyce can
even use lights to communicate, though we
don’t how this works on Will’s end – how
can he even see the lights and letters from
the Upside Down?
Some people think this means Will has psychic
powers like Eleven – which could maybe also
explain this weird gate-like thing Will seems
to open – but the evidence still isn’t
strong.
Anyway the Upside Down can also affect Hawkins
through magnetism – apparently the gate
has a strong electromagnetic field.
And sound can cross the dimensions – Jonno
hears Nancy when she’s in the Upside Down.
The very walls in Hawkins can give way to
the Upside Down – which allows the monster
to enter.
The monster, also called the Demogorgon, is
a creature that looks kinda like a human,
but with long arms, and five unfolding ‘petals’
of teeth instead of a face.
After Eleven makes the gate, the monster is
able to make small portals of its own, crossing
into Hawkins, to drag prey into the Upside
Down.
Like a shark, it’s apparently drawn by blood.
The monster hunts for food, but it also uses
prey for other purposes – in Episode 8,
we see that Will has been stuck in some gross
organic fleshy web, like in Alien, with a
slimy tentacle down his throat like a Facehugger.
Maybe, like in Alien, the creature uses human
hosts to reproduce.
Maybe the little slugs that emerge from the
bodies of Barb and Will are little baby demogorgons.
Though that doesn’t explain the hatched
egg we see earlier on in the Upside Down – maybe
that’s the egg the monster hatched from,
but if so, what laid the egg?
It looks too big to come out of a Demogorgon.
Also, the first time we see the monster, it
looks like its eating that same egg.
So between the monster, the eggs, the facehugger-tentacles,
and the cough-up slugs, there must be some
complex symbiotic life-cycle happening here,
there must be more creatures involved – maybe
there are big egg-laying slug queens, or juvenile
demogorgons out there.
Maybe this creature is an alien.
Or maybe the monster is something more human.
One popular theory is that the monster somehow
represents Eleven’s darker half, like, maybe
the monster is a psychic manifestation of
her anger and fear, and her suffering at the
Hawkins Lab, and that in that moment of contact
when the gate was made, she brought the monster
out of her subconscious and into the real
world – maybe that’s what El means when
she says “I’m the monster”.
This idea could help explain some similarities
between El and the monster, like in Episode
1, we see the monster open a lock without
touching it, just as Eleven locks a lock – the
monster appears to have telekinetic abilities,
just like El.
Also, Eleven seems to recognise a photo of
Will without having met him before – maybe
she recognises him because her other half,
the monster, has abducted Will.
When El defeats the monster, both she and
the monster disappear, as though they kinda
cancelled each other out.
Maybe El and the monster merged back into
one, the monster returning to its place in
El’s consciousness – maybe changing her
for the worse.
All that said, if El is the monster, how do
we explain the complex biology of the Upside
Down?
Could that have possibly come from El’s
mind?
Finally, it’s very interesting that when
El uses her powers, we see the same weird
electrical effects that are associated with
the Upside Down, so there’s gotta be some
link here.
It’s all very uncertain, but there are clearly
strong connections between Eleven and the
monster and the Upside Down.
At the end of Season 1, El and the monster
disappear, Will comes home, and we get a ‘one
month later’, where everything seems calm
and normal.
The Byers have Christmas dinner, the boys
play D and D. Steve and Nancy get Jon a camera
to replace the one Steve broke.
All seems well.
But we see some newspaper clippings that show
there’s still a lot going on.
Joyce has told the media about Brenner’s
experiments at the Lab, leading to a “massive
investigation”.
The coroner who was involved in Will’s fake
body has been caught, and there’s a shake-up
among the State Troopers, who worked with
Brenner’s people to cover stuff up.
It seems that the secrets of the Hawkins Lab
are being revealed to the world – but it
may be that nothing comes of this, because
MKUltra was supposedly exposed before.
But there are more cool details.
The article quotes someone called Ives expressing
disgust about the Lab, which is weird cause
Becky Ives doesn’t seem to believe any of
this conspiracy stuff, and Terry Ives doesn’t
seem to speakj – so what’s going on?
Is Terry talking again?
Could she maybe have a reunion with her daughter,
Eleven?
Finally, the article mentions Brenner.
Last we saw him, he was attacked by the monster
– but this suggests he survives, and comments
from Brenner’s actor and the Duffer Brothers
have all but confirmed that we will be seeing
him again.
Which brings us to Season 2.
Season 2 of Stranger Things is set for release
in 2017, and there’s already a lot of info
out about it.
The show’s creators, the Duffer Brothers,
have said the season will be like a “sequel”
to the first.
Apparently it’ll explore the repercussions
of everything that happened last season, while
also introducing “new problems and questions”.
There’ll be new characters, including Max
and Billy and Roman.
Max is a sort of a tomboy with a complicated
history, Billy is her step-brother, hyper-confident
and violent, and Roman is an outsider with
a rough past who seeks revenge for a great
loss suffered at an early age.
All these guys sound potentially interesting,
it’ll be cool to see how they fit with the
existing cast.
Also, a teaser trailer for Season 2 has released
nine episode titles, which give tantalising
hints of what’s to come.
The first title, Madmax is evocative of the
Mad Max movies, but probably refers to the
character Max.
The Boy Who Came Back to Life has a Harry
Potter vibe, but we know this refers to Will,
just like on the newspaper.
A lot of the other stuff could kinda mean
anything – the pumpkin patch could maybe
be like a field of eggs like in Alien, the
palace could be some kind of important base,
the storm could be general metaphorical conflict
or maybe, more literally, some kinda interdimensional
Upside Down-y kinda storm?
A pollywog is a tadpole, like the pokéman,
which could perhaps refer to these slugs if
they’re, like, baby demogorgons.
The secret cabin sounds like a good place
for Eleven or someone to hide.
And the brain could maybe refer to some intelligence
behind the creatures of the Upside Down, maybe
some hivemind shit.
Finally the lost brother might refer to a
test subject like Eleven who was taken away
from their sibling – maybe this is the “great
loss” Roman suffered.
So there are a million cool new possibilities
for Season 2 here, but let’s also have a
look at what might happen to the characters
we already and love.
Season 1 ends with this creepy scene where
Will coughs up a slug, just like the one that
came out of Barb, and then then seems to flicker
for a moment into the Upside Down.
Apparently the Upside Down has done something
bad to Will, and there are a lots of different
theories about what this may be.
Since he got facehugger-tentacled, some people
think he’s got monster eggs or monster slugs
growing inside him, or even that he’s turning
into a monster.
Another possibility is that his time in the
Upside Down has given him some kind of power
to see into that dimension, that he’s connected
somehow.
But there also questions about how this has
affected Will as a person.
Like, he’s seen some shit, right?
He struggled to survive in a nightmare bizarro
world, hunted a horrific monster, isolated
from all he knows, for a week, at the age
of, like twelve – that must have had an
impact on him, surely, so Season 2 might explore
this.
But the character we really care about here
is Eleven, right?
When and how will she come back?
We do know that she’ll be back if only cause
of those waffles Hopper leaves out for her.
But what’ll happen with her character?
She’s got this great identity conflict,
where one hand she wants to be pretty, and
she wants to be normal, while on the other
hand, she grew up as a government “weapon”,
and sees herself as a monster.
This is why her relationship with Mike is
so beautiful – he doesn’t want her to
wear a wig, or be a weapon – he accepts
her for who she is.
But El still has a long way to go in working
out her identity, and hopefully Season 2 will
continue to explore this.
There are also questions about her powers.
We’ve seen El throw a van into the air,
levitate people, smoosh peoples brains, make
a kid pee.
Project herself across space and dimensions,
rip holes in spacetime itself.
What else might she be capable of?
We got a taste of her greater power in her
confrontation with the monster – her eyes
go kinda red and she goes all Super Saiyan
on the monster’s ass.
There are lots of parallels here with the
Marvel Comics character Jean Grey, who transforms
into a massively powerful psychic being called
Dark Phoenix.
The comic in which this happens, X-Men #134,
is specifically referenced in Stranger Things
by Dustin and Will.
So maybe, as with Jean Grey, we’ll see a
wilder, much more destructive side to Eleven
in Season 2.
Another great character is Hopper.
Season 1 explored his grief over the death
of his daughter Sarah, and we see his memories
of her driving him in the search for Will.
It seems like he still needs some closure
here, and there are hints that there might
be more to reveal about Sarah’s death – Hopper’s
actor describes it as a secret.
Some fans speculate that Sarah might have
had powers like El.
Also there are also questions about Hopper’s
connections to Brenner and the government
men.
In Episode 8 we see Hopper get in a black
government car – what’s he up to?
We know earlier in the Episode Hop made a
deal with Doctor Brenner – Brenner let Hop
and Joyce through the gate, and in return,
Hop gave Brenner… what?
The likely answer is that Hop told Brenner
where to find Mike and El – that’s how
Brenner knew to come to the high school gym.
You can argue that that was the right strategic
move – Will’s life was at stake, and Eleven
can protect herself, but still – Hop totally
betrayed them.
If Joyce and the boys find out, we could have
problems.
Finally, it’d be great to find out more
Brenner and the Lab and the government men,
the “bad men” – we don’t even know
what to call these guys cause we really don’t
know who they are.
Hop suggests “the CIA, the NSA, Department
of Energy”, others say they’re military,
we know they were working with the State Troopers,
but it’s really unclear who these guys are.
We’ve seen them do some extreme shit – they
murdered Benny and made it look like a suicide,
they drugged and bugged Hop, they moved Barb’s
car to make it look like she ran away, they
made a lifelike fake corpse of a dead child.
They listen in on everyone’s phone calls,
they use these Hawkins Power and Light guys
to spy.
Whoever they are, these guys have heaps of
resources, and are ruthless in pursuing their
goals.
But what are their goals?
Clearly they’re interested in Eleven’s
psychic powers, but there must be more to
it – why was Brenner so keen to get El to
make contact with the monster?
What do they know about the Upside Down?
Who else might they have experimented on?
If Eleven is the eleventh subject, are there
ten or more other subjects out there?
The Duffers have promised “a lot more backstory”
bout Brenner and Eleven and all that, so it’ll
be awesome to dig deeper into that history.
So basically Season 1 of Stranger Things was
pretty bloody great, and the sequel Season
2 is looking pretty good too.
What questions would you like to see answered
next season and what do you want to see next
from Alt Shift X?
Remember to like and subscribe, and check
out our Game of Thrones vids if you’re keen.
Thanks to the Patrons wh  o support this
channel on Patreon, including The Steve Franchise,
Stephanie Nasti, Phillip Bond, Jacob Zachs,
Rourke McLaren, Jennifer Himelic, vijay singh,
Benjamin Noggle, Hallgeir S. K., Allie & Bill
Quinn, and RIP Bosman Bonus Bits. Cheers.